you were doing more voice than that yeah  right  a lot more let's keep that lid on okay  I'd be working and giving and they'd be  saying mm-hmm  we don't hear it we're not getting this  in the booth thank you you're stuck  working more intimately with Robbie with  the micro whatever think of this one  okay maybe one less like feel a little  bit more so what I finally had to do was  we had to turn off all the lights in the  studio I wanna know where people are  wrong breath and I just I had to sit  like this I had to close my eyes and I  had to just cover up my face like this  and do all the work like that  [Music]  wouldn't you think I'm the girl girl who  has everything I just had to pretend  like I was underwater  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]